Here's what we came up with.
Remember, this is by no means
the only way to build this site.
I'm sure your sites look totally
different than this one.
And that is totally cool.
Like always,
when I started working on this.
I started with a small viewport.
At a glance the most
noticeable improvement.
Is the fact that the text
is now a lot larger.
This is a nice change,
to help improve readability.
As to the new location column
in the sports score table, well,
it disappeared on mobile.
When there's enough room for
the locations, I went ahead and
added Display Block, to the location
class to make them show back up.
When the viewport is now
in the desktop range.
I decided to shrink the text in
the Sports table, to make room for
the location.
While I would rather
make a totally different,
snazzier table to make everything fit,
I thought that making the font smaller
was a nice compromise to keep all
the information I wanted in the table.
Next on my list of changes
is the Latest News section.
In the old version,
I didn't really like the way the text
was wrapping around these images.
And I also didn't like the fact that
these images were just so small.
I decided to give myself
a little bit of flexibility.
So I turned each article or
snippet, into a flexbox.
You can tell that at the smallest screen
size, I've totally dropped the thumbnail
images, and I've gone ahead and
cropped the text to three lines.
Adding this ellipses here to
the end of the last line,
isn't super simple actually.
So if you want to do the same,
I suggest starting with the link that
you can find in the instructor notes.
As the page gets wider,
the images show back up, and
they scale with the width of the page.
Next up, I tackle the thumb
nail images for the articles.
Originally, these images were being
scaled down from an image that
was something like 2000 by 1400 pixels,
which is just absolutely massive.
And way too big for this use.
So I used image processing software,
to scale the image down to
twice the resolution of the largest
resolution thumbnails could take.
With this layout, thumbnails don't get
any larger than 245 by 164 pixels.
High density displays,
need higher density images.
So, I scaled the image
down to 490 by 327 pixels,
which is a much smaller file.
To learn more about using
images responsively and
responsibly, try our Responsive Images
Course, made by Google's Sam Dutton.
For the final version of this project.
I put all of my code in to final.css.
It's essentially just
a series of breakpoints, and
then small changes to the snippets and
scores.
I'm not going to go in-depth
to my code at the moment.
But the instructor notes,
has instructions on how to download and
play with my source code.
All in all, I'm pretty happy with
my copy of The Brighton Times.
But, this is just my layout.
I want to see what you've done, too.
Make sure that you post all
of your sites in the forums.